in producing uh digital content you know
both of these guys are producers in
their own right you know they said steve
needs to find something like a pitching
machine i'll go find that all right
that's my latest request it's a pitching
machine so are you still doing like
what's uh are you still doing some crazy
things yeah picture machine yeah is that
next that's actually something you're
getting
my i don't even mind i'll say what the
idea is i i i'm in love with this
company called liquid death right there
they're hilarious they it's canned water
they have sparkles
oh by the way can i get one i'd [ __ ]
need one dude are they no they can't
beat them in the fridge
yeah in any case one of these cans okay
it's a 16 i'm selling it back but i just
i see that it's the same circumference
size roughly as a baseball okay so i
feel like with the pitching machine with
the two wheels that if you were to
to file to stick it in there that it
would shoot the cannon i think i could i
think i could shoot a can of water a
hundred [ __ ] miles an hour out of uh
a pitching machine and if i'm
thank you and if i'm wearing a catcher's
uh mask
right with like you know and i got my
head up against like something like a
hundred miles an hour like can right
into my face with the catcher's mask on
i think uh it's doable i like it i like
it i would definitely protect your neck
because i think if it if it missed the
mist right right right right right right
so my concern is also the metal
shrapnel that will continue going
that that that into your face
maybe it's not gonna kill you but but if
there's like a grid here i don't know
well they have the visors catch during
the sunny games
there you go
protecting the sun
and i wonder if it all works it'll be
fun trying to see it yesterday right and
um it's it's and when i think it's
particularly funny we found uh on
craigslist i think it is
offer up like a guy selling one it's
like 800 bucks for this pitching machine
and i'm ready to buy it but i want to
make sure it works so we'll show up in
person and say hey before we commit to
this you know i need to stick a camera
in there
yeah
yeah what do you what if he's like but
you can only do it if you got to put a
ball in it because again what are you
saying you're only going to buy it if
the can goes through but he's like
because in his eyes he's going to be
like hey it works if a ball you put a
ball in it'll work
i don't know if the candle works exactly
so
the cam's got to work i'm not buying i
think you can create it i think you can
crank it like this and it goes from like
a softball
to a ball it's true that makes sense it
does yeah because yeah because you would
want think it would yeah change but the
um the like
you know
it grabs the ball the texture of the
outside of the ball and shoots it this
might be kind of slippy you know that'll
work because they do they don't want
conversation
yeah but footballs are grippy they're
leather
this is
metal so do you know these cats it's
funny i do i do we just had these on
clerks three and they were handing them
out and i'm like bro i don't drink beer
man
i'm like oh wait it's it's water and
it's called the tall boys they're
awesome they're awesome they all really
are though it took me a while to wrap my
head around it as a sober guy when they
first said i was like i was like oh man
like bad
but so i i'm gonna say here if if this
works i feel like if you do attempt this
maybe i can be part of it and i could be
the one throwing the can in there hey
man can i do it i love it
do
i'm generally like as much of a reckless
[ __ ] as i can be like pretty thought
through when it comes to stuff like i'm
like i like it again i'm down i'm
throwing it out there i'm down if i'm
dead that's possible i love it man yeah
dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states
then you better go to stevo.com and
check out my tour schedule hurry up and
get your tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude